okay so the two official ways to get
high school teens from different cliques
to all group together are breakfast in
detention or a killer who stalks you in
your dreams a Nightmare on Elm Street
okay so I think now officially all the
70's 80's horror movies have been remade
but Freddie was always my favorite why
because he had personality personally
for my money Rorschach was perfect to
fill those shoes okay so we all know the
premise a bunch of teens played by
20-something year olds are all being
terrorized by a guy who looks like a
burned version of the vampire from 30
days of night and he terrorizes them
where they're not safe in their dreams
only thing is if they're dying their
dreams they die in real life this man of
course is Freddy Krueger who claims of
course he was innocent of his crimes in
life yeah don't they all I personally
think the Rorschach Freddy was much
darker than the Robert Englund Freddy I
mean he does still have that smartass
Ness that made Freddy memorable but for
the most part he's just not here for
laughs most the time it seems like he
sounds like Christian Bale tried to
sound in dark night I haven't even touch
you yet Oh chefs Jonah I'm not talking
bad not gonna lie his voice is pretty
menacing in this movie now for what it
is Nightmare on Elm Street is
automatically head and shoulders above
the other horror movie remakes due to it
having a cooler premise he kills you in
your dreams and a villain who talks and
has personality so screwing this up
would be like screwing up Top Ramen but
was it cool I enjoyed the [ __ ] out of it
I mean you're not gonna find any critics
using over the used artsy elitist talk
to describe the movie Nightmare on Elm
Street was a magnum opus it's a to ative
fool so true delights but for what it is
and especially if you're a horror movie
fan it's enjoyable as hell and how were
the teens in this movie fine they did
what they're supposed to do they died
and thanks to Fredi they did it well
there were actually a lot more Freddy
dream sequences in this movie that I
thought there'd be that was a really
nice surprise I thought there'd be like
1 or 2 and then the rest of the movie be
like concentrating on the deeper meaning
of it and what it all means but now
nightmares and people die and with
today's special effects they're able to
do like a lot of really neat things in
the dreams and show reality shift to the
dream in a really cool way I thought
that was neat now if you've seen the
previous Freddy movies or if you're a
Freddy fan you'll notice a few throw
backs references and shout outs and it
might just tickle your inner Freddy fan
yeah I said tickle and if you're not a
Freddy fan or you've never seen a
nightmare and
street movie I gotta believe you're in a
cave with Ben Laden but hey now's a good
time to start Nightmare on Elm Street
has a cool premise a really cool actor
filling the Freddy shoes and it's a lot
of fun people might argue that the
original is better but are they sure
about that I mean this one's less cheesy
than the original it's darker than the
original I found it to be more intense
than the original granted it's less
original than the original it being a
remake and all and I understand that the
original is more nostalgic than the new
one but nostalgia does not mean better
just means you're more attached to it so
what's the same premise as the old
Freddy and I for one enjoyed it for what
it was so check it out if you like scary
movies and now for my review of furry
vengeance if you consider watching this
movie God's going to punch you in the
neck quick period and that's it